Yesterday, congressional
Republicans unveiled their plan
to replace Obamacare.
It's called
the "American Health Care Act."
It's basically just a wet sock
filled with ibuprofen
-and a Post-it note that says
"Good luck." -(laughter)
But Jason Chaffetz,
the Utah Republican congressman
who looks like a Rescue Ranger
with a G.I. Joe doll haircut,
defended the proposal
on CNN this morning
in a way that would make
Marie Antoinette proud.
Americans have choices,
and they've got to make
a choice, and so maybe rather
than getting that new iPhone
that they just love,
and they want go to spend
hundreds of dollars on that,
maybe
they should invest
in their own health care.
They've got to make
those decisions themselves.
-Yeah, (bleep) you, millennials!
-Yeah! -(laughter)
If you just forgo
that $749 iPhone 7,
you can literally pay for
two percent of an appendectomy.
-Oh! -HARDWICK: "Iconic image
of a woman deciding
between health care and that
sweet new iPhone she wanted."
-Oh, Jesus.
-Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
-It's the Dust Bowl photo lady.
-Yeah.
-She...
-Now, of course... What?
-She has an iPhone 3. Just
saying. -HARDWICK: She has a...
Of course
as a member of Congress,
-this melted The Rock Popsicle
gets... -(laughter)
...sweet, sweet subsidized
government health care.
But not only that.
It turns out
Chaffetz's political
action committee pays
for his Verizon bill.
Comedians, what's another
of his money-saving tips
for people without health care?
Beth.
You could save money on gas
for your commute
by dying in your sleep.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
So easy.
-HARDWICK: No more premiums.
-No. -Yeah.
HARDWICK:
Points. Yes.
If you hold your breathe
long enough,
God will take care
of everything else.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes, Randy.
At least that's how I got
my iPhone. Wait. No?
-(laughter)
-Very good. Jay.
One small penis-removal surgery
will save tons
-of money on Viagra.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, absolutely.
-RANDY: A very smart choice.
-(applause and cheering)